our guest tonight one of the biggest
groups on the planet to do have a map of
the soul seven is out now yes what do
you do when you're one of the biggest
musical acts in the world anything that
you freaking want and that's just what
BTS proved on Monday when they took over
New York City's Grand Central Terminal
to perform their new single on on The
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon yeah
the seven members of the kpop band
busted out some killer moves in the
middle of the train station like it was
no biggie
[Music]
[Applause]
guys this is a biggie 750,000 people are
said to travel through Grand Central
every day
and not a single other human was seen
during their performance well except for
those backup dancers and that marching
band but you get the point
they straight-up cleared the joint out
damn but Grand Central wasn't the only
spot in the city that they hit up
welcome to the New York City subway what
do you think first impression hotdogs
coffee
Oh mommy New Yorkers like scarfing like
I'm so didn't for the business and you
know really yeah I love them movie home
alone oh yeah classic that's a classic
in Korea really the boys talked all
things New York and all things BTS on
the subway does it get any more legit
than that how has it been coming to the
United States and having people respond
to your music good day baby
your time you got watch okay tell me Joe
I love you I mean are you surprised at
how big it became um yeah of course
um like he said it came from a small
label in a small country from Asia so I
think you know we can prove that I'm
someone from like outside to be in the
mainstream yes so I think that's why we
feel so happy and they shared what they
would be doing if BTS had never become a
thing heaven forbid tennis player I'm
actor pro gamer producer or someone
write her post at ouch oh oh
don't thank my job leading up to bts's
appearance the show asked fans to submit
questions for the band which led to
hashtag felon asks BTS to trend at
number one worldwide not surprising but
yeah number one worldwide people anyway
the guys answered some of those
questions like what the heck is up with
that black bean noodle incident oh you
got a dirty Sunday good day
toy I know you did I'm sure she knows
she got you know what she going and
timing in Russia Gondar wall
DJ cling to the wall guru what da Shi D
so we talked he that even I had a
stomachache glad we got to the bottom of
that and they revealed there's one celeb
that they are dying to meet is there any
audience that you want to grab that you
haven't got the opportunity to meet yeah
John Cena John Cena want to see him he's
a big fan of us and yet we're the big
fan and yeah of course uh hey guys can
we get John Cena on the line we have an
intro to make okay yeah John told ety
he's a proud member of the BTS army I'm
petitioning to kind of be there
their secret bodyguard when I became
aware of the BTS phenomenon it hit me by
storm
I listened to their music I enjoy their
music j-hope is my favorite just because
he's got a little bit of street cred
like himself but I'm I really enjoyed
the following and the passion they
create I think that that's something
special of course all this fun in NYC is
to promote their new album map of the
soul 7 and their upcoming global tour
it's gonna be harder it's gonna be
whatever you're expecting it is it's
gonna be
and harder but before the guys hit the
road on tour fans can watch them hit the
road with James Corden for a little
carpool karaoke et recently caught up
with BTS and they filled us in on what
we can't expect it took like three four
hours really yeah and I've heard that
it's like the biggest car they ever
rented oh because we're selling so what
kind of car was it like some fan but
really hot yeah inside the cow I was
like what 16 cameras inside no Gordon
was not really driving it aha he like we
I didn't know like I I think I thought
he really goes yeah oh yeah safety first
safety first something tells me that
these seven guys crammed in a car with
James is going to make for an epic TV
moment and I'm here for it of course
you can count on et to bring you all the
latest on BTS so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens I'll see you soon
[Music]